the rock may seem like a larger than
life figure but even he's gone through
his fair share of hard times
from major setbacks to skyrocketing
success and wrestling in films this is
the story of how dwayne the rock johnson
worked hard to turn his poverty into
star power
today rocky solomon johnson is mainly
known as the rock's dad but he once had
a respectable wrestling career of his
own
rocky whose father was also a wrestler
started in the 60s and found
considerable success after joining the
wwe
then known as the wwf in 1983.
in december of that same year soul man
and tony atlas defeated the wild samoans
and became the first african-american
tag team in wwe history
rocky retired eight short years later
but he made enough of an impact to get
inducted into the wwe hall of fame in
2008.
unsurprisingly it was rocky who first
introduced young dwayne to wrestling
often teaching his son simple holds and
maneuvers and introducing him to the gym
at the age of 13.
sadly rocky passed away in 2020 at age
75
his son said of him on instagram i love
you you broke color barriers became a
ring legend and trailblazed your way
through this world
i was the boy sitting in the seats
watching and adoring you my hero from
afar
the boy you raised to always be proud of
our cultures and proud of who and what i
am the boy you raised with the toughest
of love
dwayne johnson was born in 1972 by the
mid-80s he had moved around more than
most people ever do in their entire
lives spending at least a few months in
13 states after moving to the u.s from
new zealand
johnson told the hollywood reporter back
in 2014 we were living in an efficiency
that cost 120 dollars a week
we come home and there's a padlock on
the door and an eviction notice
my mom starts bawling she started crying
and breaking down
where are we going to live what are we
going to do it was one of the darkest
moments of his life
and if that wasn't bad enough he'd spent
the weeks leading up to that eviction
getting into dangerous underground
fights and even stealing to help his
mother pay bills after her car was
repossessed
they eventually moved to nashville
tennessee got evicted there and wound up
in pennsylvania
all over the course of 1987. it was one
of the periods in his life that brought
johnson to a fork in the road
given a crime in despair or work his way
out of the mess
as a teenager dwayne johnson didn't
simply commit a crime here or there
he was part of a self-described theft
ring that landed him in jail at least
eight times by age 17.
as he told muscle and fitness there are
a lot of tourists that come into waikiki
hawaii and there's a lot of money
a lot of foreign money that comes in and
we were part of a theft ring that would
target those groups we would target the
money we would target the high-end
clothes and we would target the jewelry
turn around and sell it best we could
johnson didn't love having to turn to
illegal schemes to keep his family
afloat
luckily for him he was spending as much
time lifting at the gym during this
period as he was lifting jewelry
and it was for the same reasons his
family's experience with poverty and
desperation led him to unconventional
solutions
go ask anyone on the street what comes
to mind when they think of dwayne
johnson
chances are that 95 of the answers
you'll get will be about wrestling
movies or working out
almost nobody would mention football but
that's exactly where the future wwe star
got his start in professional sports
of course it's not exactly surprising
given the fact that he was six foot five
and 290 pounds of pure muscle when he
joined the miami hurricanes as a
freshman in 1991.
over his four years with the team he
appeared in 39 games and made a
respectable 77
tackles nothing mind blowing but it gave
the future rock his first taste of true
success
crucially it proved to him that the
years of work he put into bettering
himself could pay off
after a few years of playing successful
college football dwayne johnson appeared
to have a bright future in the sport
ahead of him
sadly it wasn't meant to be his career
ended before
it truly took off in the same way so
many young athletes careers do
with a series of debilitating injuries
johnson told sports illustrated in
february 2021
i tore everything in my shoulder which
meant that i red-shirted and spent the
season on injured reserve
i was so depressed during that stretch
according to the hollywood reporter
johnson was eventually restored to his
standing in the team after spending
weeks in despair with a bandaged arm
even found his old passion again but
more injuries followed
when the nfl came around in 1995 they
skipped him in the draft
despite being skipped over by the nfl
johnson did find work on a professional
football team
the calgary stampeders it wasn't where
he wanted to be and the money
300 a week was pitiful compared to what
he would have made in the nfl
but at least it was something however
his time with the stampeders was
painfully brief
he played a handful of games with the
team but he struggled to stand out
amongst an already stellar defensive
lineup
he was eventually bumped to the practice
team and he was barely making enough
money to eat
soon after the rock was cut from the
stampeders entirely and he went back to
live with his parents in florida
johnson then fell into one of the
darkest periods of his life struggling
with severe depression
after getting cut from the calgary
stampeders johnson spent several weeks
at his parents florida apartment
dealing with feelings of hopelessness
and despair after nearly two months of
living at home the head coach of the
stampeders called him up and asked him
to return to the team
johnson thanked him and said he'd think
about it but his mind was made up
he never called back dwayne then told
his parents that he was putting football
behind him so he could go into the
family business
wrestling his father was stunned johnson
recalls being told that he was making a
terrible mistake and ruining his career
however after seeing that his son was
serious and passionate about the move
rocky agreed to train him and the rest
as they say is history
when it comes to anything but especially
professional wrestling you don't start
at the top
and nobody knows that better than dwayne
johnson as he told stephen colbert in
2018
i would wrestle i had a guarantee of 40
per match every night and johnson often
found himself wrestling in rings set up
in the middle of flea markets or the
parking lots of used car dealerships
and people go in they buy used cars and
if you want you can see free wrestling
matches
it was far from glamorous but the future
star knew that if he wanted to hit the
big times he had to pay his dues
even if things were awkward or
embarrassing as the man himself put it
i would be there with my pineapple
haircut and i would
be putting on my boots and wrestling
gear
next to an office who was trying to sell
cars it was the oddest thing
as dwayne johnson was working his way
through the lowest levels of the
wrestling world he got a lucky break
when his father's friend pat patterson
caught wind of his amateur matches
a professional wrestler himself
patterson was impressed by johnson's
abilities
and he told wwf ceo vince mcmahon that
he had to come see the kid train
johnson told the story in an instagram
post following patterson's death in
december 2020.
as johnson told it he was around 24
years old when patterson called up
mcmahon telling him
i just watched this kid dwayne johnson
work out in the ring he's only been
training for three months but vince you
got to see this kid mcmahon agreed and
from there
well dwayne johnson's future was set
dwayne johnson didn't start out as the
rock
he actually debuted in the 1996 survivor
series as rocky mayavia which was a
combination of his father's and
grandfather's wrestling names
it wasn't just his name that was
unrecognizable rocky came out and a
rather bizarre outfit consisting of a
checkered board neck piece lined with
feathers and draping blue tassels
despite this madison square garden gave
the newcomer the benefit of the doubt
the wwf which would eventually become
the wwe dubbed him the blue chipper
and played around with his family's
extensive wrestling background heavily
hyping johnson as a third generation
wrestler he won a string of matches and
was getting considerable title
consideration within a year of his debut
but the fans weren't having it
they thought the wwf was trying to ram
rocky's superstar qualities down their
throats before they had time to get to
know him and they made their distaste
known by audibly chanting rocky sucks
and die
rocky die at his matches the wwf had
invested heavily into wayne johnson
but it was obvious his rocky mayavia
character wasn't going over well with
the fans who saw him as being
prematurely hyped as a future champion
before they'd gotten to know him at all
it was clear that johnson's family
history in wrestling wasn't enough he
needed to carve his own path
so they changed course johnson ditched
his blue drapes and chipper identity for
black leather trunks and a
no-holds-barred trash-talking persona
thus the rock was born johnson debuted
the rock as a heel a wrestling villain
in 1997 as a member of the nation of
domination
he often referred to himself in the
third person and insulted the audience
and his rivals in the ring
most notably he developed an
in-character feud with fellow legend
stone cold steve austin during this
period
one that lasted well beyond his nation
of domination days
the fans loved it and johnson found his
niche in a 1997 story line the rock
delighted fans by backstabbing teammate
peru and taking over the nation of
domination
but it was becoming abundantly clear
that the rock was too popular to be
stuck in a team
after a high-profile defeat for which he
blamed the nation he disbanded
the team and struck out on his own
superstardom awaited
by 1999 the rock went solo and quickly
established himself as a smooth
trash-talking attitude era villain and a
wrestler to be reckoned with
his first wwf championship win was in
the 1998 survivor series where he
defeated mankind in the finals
he lost the title to mankind in january
1999 but the rock won it back in a royal
rumble i quit match
in a latter match less than a month
later the rock defeated mankind again
and won his third wwf championship
he won a fourth championship the
following year against triple h
a fifth that june a sixth in february
2001 and a record-breaking seventh in
july 2002.
he eventually won his eighth and final
wwe belt against cm punk in january
2013.
by that time the people's champion had
become not only one of the most popular
wrestlers of all time but a pop culture
icon whose star power had arguably
outgrown the ring entirely
after portraying his own father on a
1999 episode of that 70s show the rock
made his theatrical acting debut in
2001's the mummy returns
he returned for the scorpion king
prequel the following year the films
received lukewarm reviews but the
negative reception hardly put a dent in
johnson's rising star power
and reviews of his acting abilities were
positive he's hardly taken any serious
time away from acting since
and the a-lister has appeared in over 40
films
daddy's gotta go to work
in both 2019 and 2020 johnson topped
forbes list of highest-paid actors in
the world
not like he needs the financial help far
from his poverty-stricken days as a
teenage thief johnson sells clothes has
written books and has even made some
wildly popular returns to the wwe
he's currently one of the most popular
men on the planet but none of it came
easy
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie stars are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one